all right let's go through uh a few
different news stories from the last 24
hours today is the nra convention
national rifle association in houston
texas it is also texas the state
the site of the deadliest mass shooting
in a school since sandy hook a decade
ago
and donald trump is going to be speaking
at the nra convention greg abbott is
going to be speaking there ted cruz is
going to be speaking there and all of
them blame everything other than guns
for the mass shooting that took place
earlier this week that's what
republicans do
there has been increased pressure that i
mean listen there's been pressure that
the convention not even happened it's a
vile event by an organization whose goal
is just to sell guns their clients are
the gun manufacturers they are paid by
gun manufacturers
to increase demand for guns that's what
they do but short of the event being
canceled
there's been pressure on people like
donald trump not to speak there but
donald trump plans to speak there and he
is doubling down posting to his
uh
you know his i guess it's a social media
platform truth social truth essential
yeah he posted quote
america needs real solutions and real
leadership in this moment not
politicians and partisanship
that's why i will keep my longtime
commitment to speak in texas at the nra
convention and deliver an important
address to america
in the meantime we will continue to pray
for the victims their families and for
our entire nation we are all in this
together
going on to say a horrible time for our
country
the idea that because we need solutions
it makes sense to speak at the nra the
nra is never going to have a solution to
school shootings or shootings in general
the nra wants more people to buy guns
one of the ways that you get people to
buy more guns
is to make them believe that it's really
dangerous out there or to actually allow
it to be really dangerous out there it's
sort of the same thing if people think
they need a gun they're going to go and
buy a gun and then if there's fewer
shootings you go and you say hey that's
thanks to guns go out and buy more guns
either way
the nra's solution
is to buy more guns and the idea that
they are going to be an arbiter or a a
meeting point of any kind of actual
solutions is absurd it is insane
that what 96 hours after this shooting
in the same state the nra is gathering
to talk about how great guns are and how
access to them shouldn't be restricted
so trump will be speaking there it's
disgusting it's depraved it's absurd but
it's exactly what we would expect him to
do okay a sitting florida representative
randy fine who represents the 53rd
district in florida
threatened joe biden with gun violence
in the aftermath of the uvalde texas
shooting you have a shooting okay
and then joe biden wants to do something
about gun violence
and an elected official
threatens biden with guns
he tweeted quote
i have news for the embarrassment that
claims to be our president
try to take our guns and you'll learn
why the second amendment was written in
the first place that's an elected
official ladies and gentlemen he should
be immediately removed from office the
secret service should visit him and have
a nice chat
and he was confronted about what he
tweeted
and he kind of doubles down weirdly now
as a warning to people watching uh randy
fein is extremely red in this video just
as a heads up listen to this guy what a
be doofus in those who have mental
problems i think when the president of
the united states gets on the day of the
mass shooting and said he's going to
come and take people's guns away that's
incendiary
he turned his speech into a speech on
gun control it was hugely inappropriate
it was hugely inappropriate to do that
day if they are going to start this they
cannot expect us to sit silently while
they try to strip our second amendment
you know it doesn't really help your
cause when joe biden says hey i don't
know
we still haven't really tried any gun
safety regulations maybe we should for
you to threaten to shoot the president
implicitly it doesn't really help your
cause that we should be just doing
nothing about the gun element
incredible
all right he's got to go
uh and of course as usual they insist oh
it's
he's injecting politics he's injecting
politics these are decisions made by
political figures how on earth
do you address something that
politicians should deal with
without injecting politics and of course
it's used as a pejorative well you're
injecting politics oh yeah well it's a
political issue why is that bad
that should just be the i mean that
should just be the reaction yeah this is
a political issue
the people are coming to us as
politicians saying please do something
so who should they go to are they going
to go to i don't know doctors
to pass some law about guns uh it's an
absurd situation and even more absurd is
that this guy is trying to say it would
be really bad to take anyone's guns even
though that's not what joe biden said
it would be really bad to take people's
guns and to prove to you how bad of an
idea it would be
i'm going to threaten to use my gun on
the president
you're making the case that your guns
should be taken sir what a vile and
disgusting guy all right this next story
is kind of a mix of the gun story and
also a uh 2022 story i don't know how
many of you are aware of this and i want
to be i want to be respectful and kind
of delicate with this story but also it
there's some insanity going on there's a
guy named herschel walker
herschel walker
is uh running for senate in georgia
herschel walker is endorsed by donald
trump herschel walker is a former nfl
football player and there are now
multiple clips of him being i i don't
mean just slightly kind of uh loopy
i'm talking about complete incoherence
complete incoherence when asked about
what should be done with regard to guns
now
i don't oh man what's tough about this
is
i don't want to say this is necessarily
a story about mental illness but there
are many reports about herschel walker
that he suffers from dissociative
identity disorder that he has multiple
personalities that
so is there possibly a mental illness
component here yeah
um there is also the story or the
allegation that what we're talking about
here is a brain injury from football
that he has cte chronic traumatic
encephalopathy
but
it also feels wrong to say this is
simply a brain injury because
this guy is a right winger either way
and in terms of his ideas he
he has had terrible ideas for a long
time so i think if we just say this is a
brain injury we're also not we're also
doing a disservice but take a look at
these clips a manu raju from cnn
approached herschel walker the other day
and asked him do you think we need new
gun laws because of what happened in
texas
and he said what i like to do is see it
and everything and stuff
that
that's his answer
okay this is the guy trump endorsed
and who won his primary in georgia
with cnn
are you do you support any new gun laws
in the wake of this texas shooting
do you support the new gun laws in the
wake of what i like to do what i like
doing
and uh and everything and stuff i like
to see it you know
my favorite new jersey so he just kind
of mumbles to himself i like to see it
and walks away
this is
complete and utter incoherence
this guy could be a senator
okay and he would be a senator on the
backs of republican votes
here's an interview he gave
yesterday morning to fox news
and
he said that a possible
solution to school shootings would be a
department
that can look at young men
that's looking at women that's looking
at social media
take a listen
see that it's a person willing that
weapon you know cain kia able you know
and uh you know and that's the problem
that we have and i said what we need to
do is look into how we can stop those
things you know they talked about doing
a disinformation what about getting a
department that can look at young men
that's looking at uh women that looking
at uh your social media what okay
what about getting a department
that's looking at young men
that's looking at women
that's looking at social media
this could be one of 100 senators
and
i want to be sensitive to
the mental illness component
the brain injury component
but this is just fundamentally
humiliating
this is the winner of the primary what
about doing that looking into things
like that and we can stop that that way
but yeah they want to just we can stop
what that way what would we stop with a
department that looks at men looking at
women looking at social media what what
on earth is that
it's like a strange uh
uh it's like the those russian
matryoshka dolls of you've got social
media and then women look at that and
men look at the women looking what are
you talking about dude continuing to
talk about taking away your
constitutional rights and and i think
there's more things we need to look into
this has been happening for years and
the way we stop it by putting money into
the mental health field by putting money
into uh other departments rather than
departments want to take away your
rights dear god
uh so that's a trump endorsed republican
you know we when when trump ran as a
republican candidate we said the
republican party would never be so dumb
as to make this guy their nominee and
they did
and then we said okay but they're not
going to be able to make this guy
president and they did and so we now see
herschel walker we need a department
that can look at young men looking at
women looking at social media we see
hershel walker saying what he wants to
do is see it in everything and stuff see
it in everything as he mumbles to
himself as he walks away and we say well
they'll never make him the republican
nominee and they did
and now we're sort of hoping they're not
going to make him one of 100 senators
are they
and
we're not going to know the answer to
that until november these are really
really scary times
let me know what you make of it find me
on twitter at d pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is an audience
supported program i would love for you
to sign up and get instant access to the
bonus show the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad sign up
at joinpackman.com we do an extra show
every single day for our members you can
also use the coupon code wow 22
to get a discount off of your membership
let's hear from people in the audience
we take calls via discord
davidpakman.com
discord uh you can not only engage in
moderated polite
discussion
uh about whatever is important to you on
the discord it's also how we take calls
uh let's start today with brad from new
york brad welcome what's on your mind
today
hey david thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
i think
what i wanted to discuss was i've been
seeing a worrying trend in that i am
pretty far left and i like to debate
conservatives
and something i'm noticing nowadays is
people are willing to be
openly racist or
openly bigoted to get their points
across and i'll give it a very quick
example um i was debating somebody i
said illegal immigration is not an issue
very vague very open
and he said the only way to save america
is to prevent the white race from being
bred out right and
i've never encountered somebody just
being blatantly racist like that i have
no idea how to
respond to that or if they're even worth
engaging with what would you suggest my
instinct is that they're not worth
engaging with but if you wanted what i
would find really interesting is to
figure out where they got those ideas
and i would start by saying oh that's
really interesting so
what makes you say that what are the
differences you you believe exists
between white and non-white people like
really drill down to exactly what the
origins of their beliefs are
when did it first occur to you that
white people are superior to non-white
people in the ways that you're
describing uh i i would find it very
interesting to really get at where those
beliefs came from but in terms of
changing those people's minds i mean i
think it would be great if we could do
it but i don't know that i would
necessarily put too much time into it if
i were you yeah my emphasis isn't
changing that person's mind it's more of
people that are listening to the debate
just by kind of uh picking their ideas
apart and it just i guess it becomes
more difficult because you can't really
logically dissect something that's
rooted in logic very or rooted in
illogic very easily right and i think
what you're getting at is you can't help
people reason their way out of positions
they didn't reason their way into to
begin with exactly yeah no i would
really out of in order to i think the
most useful thing in that type of
situation
is to i don't mean generally i mean
really specifically get to why they
believe those things because sometimes
they might say well
you know my dad is the one who
originally instructed me on this and
then i would say really
was your dad ever wrong about anything
you know i think it would open up an
interesting conversation to learn from
but like you're saying not necessarily
to change that person's mind
okay yeah because
typically what i'll do is i'll ask for
evidence yeah you know because i i
believe in data
and they'll cite the oh 1352 or whatever
other white supremacist uh talking
points they have on offhand yeah often
they don't even understand their own
talking points so i also think it's
worth getting them to explain their
views for that reason
okay thank you that was really helpful i
appreciate it my pleasure thank you so
much for the call yeah that those those
conversations are both
incredibly um uh frustrating but also
can be really illuminating if you sort
of are prepared and know uh and and know
what to ask
let's go
next to quinton from portland is that
portland maine or portland oregon
quinton from portland yes i can
oh uh portland oregon beautiful
um so i had a conversation with my
mother who was extremely extremely
right-wing okay and uh she was blaming
uh the lefties or the dems or the libs
you know whatever she wants to say uh
about leaking
the supreme court document
and
i didn't really have a rebuttal saying
that like i've heard you say that it's
more likely
a right-leaning person leaked it but i i
i couldn't really clearly tell her why i
i have that opinion so if you could just
clear that up i would really appreciate
it and then also yeah okay let's take it
piece by piece then i'll get to your
second question so to be clear what i've
said before is in terms of just
plausibility it's equally plausible that
a left winger or a right winger leaked
the supreme court decision you could say
well it's a left winger who wanted to
try to create outrage to have pressure
on the judges to change their votes and
end up uh maintaining roe v wade or you
could say it's a right winger
who decided to leak it out of fear that
some of the justices planning to
overturn roe v wade might change their
minds to put pressure on them to
maintain the positions they had in the
february draft so plausibility is kind
of equal but we have some reporting from
long-time supreme court reporters
including from npr
who say that the the overarching belief
within the court right now is that the
leaker was a right winger but ultimately
we don't know so what i would ask is
what evidence do you have to support
that the leaker was left-wing i would go
with that and of course there is no such
evidence
yeah
on a number of issues that's kind of my
response and okay
yeah um and then also um please just
google josh dallas on your show you look
like you are him oh i've been told that
before he's an actor right
yes he's an actor
you're you're slightly better looking
but yeah i mean you guys it's uncanny
i'm only slightly better looking oh boy
all right well i'll take it as a
compliment anyway
all right well thank you david i
appreciate it all right thank you so
much for the call
uh very very important stuff there
um let's see
what else we have going on let's go to
william from las vegas william welcome i
was just in las vegas not long ago
hello david uh were you here again for
another convention no no no i just mean
like a month ago
oh yes yeah all right uh so uh contrary
to your other caller you're far better
looking than that guy so just put that
out there oh good thank you i appreciate
that
i have two questions for you well um
first
how agile are the democrats going to be
in the midterm elections given that we
we repeatedly have these issues where
maniacs shoot people up
we never really solve the issue because
no one's able to find a common ground
um
adding lethal elements into a school
seems like a banana's idea that's where
they want to go
um i mean a few years back when i mean i
shut up my town there's been no progress
so how do you fight the apathy and the
you know futility of trying to to
progressively get
to a solution it's absolutely
infuriating and earlier this week after
the texas mass shooting we kind of i
went through this cycle where it's just
it's like a rinse repeat mass shooting
everybody there's media coverage
everybody says we've got to do something
a few days go by then the predominant
voice becomes republican saying whoa
whoa we can't take away any gun rights
then a few weeks or a couple months go
by and everybody kind of stops talking
about it and then there's another
shooting and it's just rinse repeat
here's my hope
i'm starting to see some polling some
not every poll but some polling that is
showing that as a result of
the forthcoming supreme court decision
on roe v wade and maybe because of the
obvious non-solutions that republicans
are proposing to the mass shooting issue
i'm starting to see some polling that's
starting to point in the direction of
november all of a sudden not looking so
bad for democrats normally it should be
a disaster for democrats joe biden just
won in 2020 you would expect democrats
to get crushed in the midterm
some new polling i'm seeing
genuinely seems to suggest that voters
are sick of what's going on
and maybe
it actually won't be bad in november and
democrats might be able to get something
done it's very very cautious optimism
but it does seem like something might be
happening here
i hope so it is so frustrating uh
especially having seen a maniac shoot up
my town and there'll be nothing done
about it yeah it just happens every day
yeah uh so my last question if you if
you don't mind sir uh i'm making my
first trip to new york city later yeah
and i wondered in brooklyn area where's
a good place a great place if you're a
tourist to get a great bagel that
represents that city oh oh okay so
listen if you are in brooklyn my
recommendation is go visit our friends
you know i actually don't know because
it's been it's been a couple months
since i've been there on smith street uh
not too far south of smith and atlantic
okay
um there's a bagel cafe
on the west side of smith street it's
right on the corner at one point it was
called mocha bagels i think now it's
called smith street bagels maybe go in
there
tell them david pakman sent you they
know me in there and that is the place i
would highly recommend they'll make you
whatever you want if you say oh i want
uh you know roast beef on a french toast
bagel with maple syrup i mean i wouldn't
recommend that by the way but
they'll make it for they'll make you
whatever you want they're the nicest
guys in there
i think that's close to where i'm at i'm
in that boreham hill dumbo area where
i'm staying so i think you're blocks
away from this you're blocks away from
this absolutely
beautiful david thank you so much for
accepting my call have a great one my
pleasure thank you
uh wow what what a big day of phone
calls here it's wild let's go next to
brian from phoenix arizona brian welcome
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
awesome i was just uh seeing today uh my
one of my home state representatives
ruben gallego uh was sending off some
fiery tweets uh in the direction of ted
cruz and some other gop reps do you
think that that kind of
engagement uh online is
effective or um would you know would
actually lead to change or do you think
it's more performative
i'm just wondering what your opinion is
about it i think that um
our lawmakers don't make policy
based on arguments they get into on
twitter but
i do think that the performance can have
some value because i want to see elected
officials who genuinely seem to care and
i've interviewed ruben and he genuinely
seems to care so to the extent that it's
authentic i don't i don't care so much
about
oh is he really going to convince other
members of the house or senate one way
or the other on twitter no i don't think
he is but
he genuinely is passionate and i don't
mind seeing that on social media
awesome and then do you expect
related do you expect any uh federal gun
control legislation to happen after this
you know i i i don't i really if i'm
honest i don't
all right thank you that's it yeah all
right no problem yeah i i mean it's sad
but
i i just don't
let's go down to texas and speak to
asher from dallas asher go
asher from dallas you're on the air
and last chance for asher
from dallas you are muted
i need you to unmute
or select your correct audio device i
can see that you're trying to talk but
no audio is coming through
that could be
an audio device issue
all right unfortunately no asher from
dallas experiencing uh an issue a
technical issue a technical issue that's
sad to uh sad to see
let's go next to doug from alabama doug
welcome
doug from alabama i can see that you
have muted yourself
all right my bad okay hey hey long time
listener david uh i just wanted to just
do like a brief rundown and just get
your opinion on something really fast
okay you know obviously we're in alabama
we got really lucky with uh doug jones a
few years ago because of the whole
fiasco
um
that's probably the most left person
that we've had
ever served because i mean we had
democrats before but they were really
like dixie dixiecrats you know they
weren't really democrats
so um you know it's it's really sad uh
with the state of the the elections down
here um
the
current like democratic um
you know nominees for governor i'm
definitely going to vote for whoever
wins
um i really think that like walt maddox
should have ran again because he was he
was kind of more like a biden kind of
centrist
democrat but he probably had the best
shot down here
um he only lost like 10 10 percentage
points last time but
uh luckily it looks like uh k ivy won so
she's still really really bad but the
the alternative was even worse but i
want to get your opinion on something i
knew i pretty much know what your answer
was going to be because i've heard your
opinion before but
you're probably going to be mad at me
but i basically i actually voted in the
primary but i wasn't you know i'm
definitely going to vote democrat in the
uh in november but i i just chose for
some reason my friend told me i was an
idiot for doing it but i just decided to
vote in the republican primary just to
get the the least evil people to win
because i know that they're basically
going to win in november so i did even
though mo brooks was like the worst
probably the worst guy that we could
vote for
his uh katy brits even worse um
in a lot of ways and you know obviously
trump doesn't like mo brooks so i kind
of just
did like a protest vote even though i
hate mo brooks and i don't want him to
win but i just i don't know
i just wanted your opinion on that i
know i know you got a show to run but i
appreciate your uh doug i i love it i
don't know what the question is but we
love phone calls from alabama and uh
please call in again okay i don't know
what the question is that that was very
interesting but i'm just not sure what
the question is we're going to take a
very quick break just hold on because
we're going right back to the phone
lines in a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow let's hear
from a few more people in the audience
after all the show is for people in the
audience it's not for me to sit in a
room by myself with a microphone as fun
as that could be we take calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord okay very very important
slash discord
why don't we speak next to harry from
columbus ohio welcome harry
david obviously can you hear me yes i
can
thanks for taking my call
um
sorry i need to drag my memory
real quickly also your audio is
atrocious it's like blinking in and out
it's like a popcorn connection
is it really really about give me one
second to try to address it all right
any better for you david you know it's
not but i think i'll i'll be able to
hear your question if you remember it
yeah i do um so i have a question about
uh dinesh de
souza last time first thing i'd heard
about it was that he was
someone who denied the the southern
strategy that was what i had
known him for can you tell me a little
bit more about him like in regards to
like you know
2000 mules even trump mentioned it
recently what do you know about dinesh
well i know he's a convicted felon um
and a grifter uh no the film we've
talked about the film two thousand mules
two thousand mules is a film by dinesh
d'souza which makes the argument that on
the basis of mobile phone geo-location
data that's quite frankly not very
accurate it makes the argument that
there were 2 000 so-called mules or
ballot traffickers
who were making massive dumps of
fraudulent ballots into ballot drop
boxes or as trump likes to call them
drock boxes
and um it's all completely
unsubstantiated
and uh it's i wouldn't spend too much
time honestly thinking about dinesh
d'souza
okay i have then real quickly more
substantially do you think um it will
be you know successful for
somebody like uh to get into ohio
politics for
uh tim ryan he seems to be trying to tap
to the middle
really hard he has an ad that says uh
you know
democrats really messed it up shipping
jobs to china but you know i'm
pro-union i'm you know pro is uh
socially
uh do you think that can work to win
over but you know suburban ohio
i think it might yeah i think it might i
mean i think i don't know enough about
the ohio electorate but i think it's
completely plausible and i support ryan
and i i hope he does crush in november
yeah i just don't know how powerful the
anti-china message is for deaf democrats
that's a fair question don't buy it yeah
we'll have to wait and see what the
results
the connection is just ungodly so we
will um we're going to let you go but i
appreciate all of the questions there a
lot of important stuff
let's go next to
let's go to schizo from north carolina
schizo you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
awesome
uh i had a question so in one of your
episodes
um on may 3rd you were talking about
esper withholding information
to make
money on a book
and you mentioned something you had
talked about
you not agreeing with
conservatism could you explain exactly
what that what that what you mean by
that and
i'm not a conservative i'm just
kind of wondering what your opinion is
on it
it you're saying what like why am i not
a conservative you're saying that's the
question no no you so you said you had
you disagree with conservatism
i'm not a conservative yeah i i don't
agree with conservative ideas i'm a
progressive but
are you saying like i'm not trying to
particularly
because um what you were talking about
you said something that
the whole aspect so the point you made
was that esper was basically like you
could say that what he did with holding
that information being treasonous
and i agree with that that's an
interesting point
and then you had said that this isn't
conservatism you disagree with
conservatism and my question is like
what is
what is it about conservatism that you
disagree with apart from you know being
a progressive
oh i guess you're asking me my political
philosophy i mean i disagree with the
economic ideas of the of conservatism
and i disagree with the social ideas of
conservatism i think the economic ideas
have been debunked empirically and i
think the social ideas are retrograde
antiquated and um completely the
opposite of of modernity i mean i don't
know i don't know if i can lay out on
every issue my political philosophy but
like my entire show is based on the idea
that i'm a progressive and i think that
those conservative ideas are bad and are
bad for the country and bad for the
people
okay understood yeah because i i'm
finding myself to be more progressive
i've never felt or
been aligned with conservatism i was
just curious because
my awakening
from
like political awakening was 2020 and i
voted for biden because at the time i
didn't really understand political
politics and stuff like that but i
voted for biden because trump just
seemed like
not the best choice
and i'm finding myself that that was the
best choice
um for 2020 but i'm fine which was which
was the best choice for 2020. biting
okay okay and how old were you in 2020
i was
28.
wow so you didn't you could have voted
in 2016 and you could have voted in 2012
but you didn't
right and there's a bit of a backstory
that obviously i'm not going to go into
for
the time
um but yeah at the time i uh
so yeah i voted for biden and one of the
other things i wanted to ask or i guess
kind of like tell you was
the interviews that you've been having
with republican candidates i've been
enjoying a lot and not from like a
laughing at them
for
still not accepting like that gut check
question where who is currently the
president of the u.s and they will
just dance around and i love it because
it makes me it's kind of like
you you're not trying to
uh directly
attack that person but the people who
are watching can kind of see hey this is
the idea that these people are having
and it sort of gets the people to kind
of like think about
why do they think that way and the
reason why i've been enjoying that is
because i am currently surrounded by a
lot of
conservative republican people
who
i don't think understand conservatism
and what they're doing is they're just
kind of repeating the talking points and
believing the conspiracies and they
don't really have a good basis
for
their their their political views well
that's very common
right and
i guess that's sort of my point is why
you disagree with it because i kind of
wanted your take on it because i i'm
still like in that journey where i'm
trying to understand
you know politics in that way
well listen i lay out all my political
views on my show any clip you find
that's me laying out my political views
so schizo from north carolina i very
much appreciate the call
i am going to move on because i've got a
bunch of other people here waiting let's
go next to daniel from texas daniel
welcome what's on your mind today
david cameron just barely daniel what's
going on
sorry i'll try to get closer to mike now
um
i was just uh uh
sorry my uh
trying to jumble this morning no
um
i'm from texas that as it says but um
i've been looking at a lot of the races
throughout the country and one of the
ones that i'm honestly most interested
in seeing the outcome of is louisiana's
senate race with gary chambers
i was wondering what your thoughts might
be about uh him whether you think he has
the um had a chance to win and
uh his platform and all that you know i
don't really know that much about that
race that's not one of the ones i've
been following uh super closely
but it seemed this to be to be accurate
this is the race in which the incumbent
is the republican senator john kennedy
who's cuckoo for coco puffs and then
you've got gary chambers and then
there's a couple of other candidates as
well right it's it's like a
non-partisan
election that's done there is it's a bit
of a different system
yeah kind of from what i've been able to
figure out it's like basically i guess
what they're going to be running at the
same time yeah
with chambers being like just under
the income and the other two kind of
like
yeah it looks like they have their
primary on november 8th and then it
looks like the top two will go to sort
of like the final election on december
10th yeah listen i don't know much about
gary chambers i know that john kennedy
is a disaster so
i i mean i it would be improper for me
to say i support chambers only because
he's not kennedy because i don't really
know anything about him but kennedy is
not a good guy and i support removing
him but i'd have to look more into the
race to be able to say any more about it
okay
oh boy all right now we're losing you
daniel the connection's going haywire so
i'm going to let you go
let's go next to
uh why don't we go to bobby from jersey
bobby welcome to the show
hello david could you hear me yes i can
okay um my question is is that what do
you think drives people to arrive at
their political conclusions do you think
it's more of a uh biological or
environmental um reasons that make them
that make them draw to that specific
conclusion so there's a couple different
things going on here this is a great
question uh one in general people's
political views do mirror those of their
parents and the community they were
raised in and the people they were
raised around so there's no question
that there's lots of people who if you
put them in a liberal family in
connecticut they're likely to end up
liberal if you put them in a
conservative family in arkansas they're
more likely to end up conservative so
one part of it is the environment you
grow up around at the same time there
are some pretty good
uh peer-reviewed studies into
the differences in brains between left
and right wingers and it's believed that
right-wingers have stronger sort of like
disgust reactions and fear reactions and
that that also appears to be a factor so
it's kind of a boring answer but it
appears to be sort of like a combination
of all these different things
oh that was actually kind of the answer
i was looking for because i've run into
stuff like that and i noticed many of
the different personality traits between
me and many of my conservative
colleagues oh what do you mean what's an
example what's a trait you notice in
your conservative colleagues
like a lot of them tend to be very
aggressive they tend to always want more
they always they're very status obsessed
very um kind
yeah so that's that's something i've
noticed thank you david all right
there's bobby from jersey with a nice uh
nice question that's a good topic yeah
there's a there's a lot of science
around that and not everybody sort of
like accepts or likes it or agrees with
the science but um
it's uh pretty interesting stuff
let's go next to um let's go to jonathan
from arkansas jonathan welcome
i'm a hello can you hear me yes i can
um yes
i was i had a question about the
arkansas governor race um
as it looks it looks uh here living in
arkansas that sarah huckabee
sanders will probably be the
will probably win the governor race it
does look that way
and uh
you know i do not want her to win at all
right i was just wondering if you have
any advice
uh if you think
i should go forth uh
for
for the
the republican washburn or if i should
just
because voting for a democrat will be a
vote thrown away uh here in arkansas
because i do not think chris jones will
will be able to beat the republican well
but hold on a second sarah huckabee
sanders earlier this week won her
primary so she's going to be on the
ballot and then jones the democrat will
be on the ballot but you're saying there
will be another republican on the ballot
in november as well
uh
yes
oh why that doesn't make sense to me
is it a write-in campaign or something
oh no no never mind uh i was talking
about the the libertarian the oh
libertarian listen vote for whoever you
agree with on the most okay that that's
my advice to you
you can decide in terms of the strategic
aspect of who to vote for but i would
just tell you vote vote for whoever you
agree with the most because quite
frankly it just seems like sarah
huckabee sanders is going to blow blow
out the win you know
yeah yeah sadly sadly
yeah i mean
andy do you think there's anything i
could do or do you think is is uh that's
the reality no listen i mean i i don't
think it's worth giving up she should be
challenged as much as possible if she's
going to win make her spend as much
money as possible to win make it as
difficult as possible for her to win so
i would figure out do you prefer the
democratic or the libertarian candidate
you can phone bank you can get involved
you can door knock it make it as hard
for her as possible and we have to
recognize it's an uphill battle because
arkansas is such a red state
yes
yes uh all right david uh i'll let you
go uh thank you for taking my call
all right thank you jonathan from
arkansas yeah it's a tough uh to tough
situation there all right thank you to
everybody who called in we are not going
to be able to speak to anyone else today
but we will speak to more people again
we'll go to a quick break and be back
right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right it's time for the friday
mailbag if you have anything you would
like to say to us to me
you can email info davidpakman.com if
it's praise if it's a criticism if it's
a demand for a correction if it's a
question a topic suggestion a guest
suggestion any of it and unfortunately
even if you just have insults we can't
really prevent you from sending the
email either and we are starting today
with the type of insult that i have to
tell you
i love this kind i get pleasure from
this because it's someone who clearly
is so
in a fantasy world about the size of our
show
that i just love this jeff wrote in and
says it's hilarious watching you post
tin foil hat conspiracy theories and
delusional rants on your tiny youtube
channel
you're just a youtuber stop pretending
you're in the same league as actual
journalist or opinion people
you're never going to be like tucker
carlson god i hope not
nobody likes you or respects you even
clowns like propaganda puppet kyle
kolinsky are several rungs above you and
that's not saying much because he's a
laughing stock of youtube political
commentators just like you so
kyle sucks too but you're even worse so
what do i love about this
we have a program that's been around 15
years
we have a larger
daily audience than many corporate media
shows that only get a few hundred
thousand viewers a day we are in the top
0.1
of all youtube channels we are the
second largest left-wing youtube channel
behind only the young turks this is a
full-time job for me
and multiple employees
we've already done the thing that he
says we will never actually do and as
far as i'm never going to be tucker
carlson that's true in two ways number
one i'm never going to be as immoral as
tucker carlson and number two
i'm never going to have the support of a
multi-billion dollar corporation behind
me because i'm happy doing it this way i
don't want to do it that way uh so jeff
you know what
you're right and i'm so happy that some
of the things you're saying are uh true
although many of them are not next email
is from dave dave says question hannity
supports a candidate on his show meaning
hand hannity supported mehmet oz in the
pennsylvania uh republican senate
primary
it used to be that if a station gave
advertising or air time to one candidate
over another candidate it had value
that value counted as a campaign
contribution i wonder if the fec would
look at this as a contribution to
certain candidates and it then be deemed
an illegal contribution if that value
went over the dollar amount set by law
or would they see it as within the rules
of what constitutes a donation or a
political contribution dave is right
that when hannity has a platform the
size of his platform and he says i
support oz for example and remember he
supported trump too so it would apply
there as well
every time that he
supports oz or attacks other people like
hannity would attack kathy barnett
another candidate running in that
primary that has a monetary value
exactly what it is would have to be
figured out
but there's no doubt that that has a
monetary value
in terms of the fec
and it being considered a contribution i
don't know
but there's also the aspect of equal
time laws
and um i don't know to what degree those
are being enforced and honestly i don't
know at this point even where they
necessarily apply but there was a time
and we were when we started on the radio
we were conscious of this particularly
in local elections when we were up in
massachusetts that's where the show
started and we would interview local
candidates we would kind of be told
you've got to at least offer everybody
in this race the opportunity to be
interviewed they won't all take you up
on it but you've got to give them that
opportunity so needless to say
the
aside from the legality of it
the kind of like unquestioning just kind
of like yeah i guess it's fine hannity
tells us who he likes
and it's just you know he's supporting
one candidate over another and everybody
just goes along their merry business as
if there's no monetary value or
influence from that it is weird
i don't know whether the fec angle
you're going to get too far with
necessarily
next email is from quinn quinn wrote in
about liz cheney quinn says david i
wanted to talk more about the liz cheney
segment you did the other day as a
democrat i feel like it's unfair to say
she isn't an ally i understand she's one
of the people who enabled trump until
january 6. but since then she's put her
career in jeopardy by being one of the
only republicans with a moral red line
it would have been great after january 6
for republicans to have an epiphany and
become civil rights advocating police
reforming marijuana legalizing
socialists but just because she didn't
do a 180 in her values doesn't or at
least shouldn't mean she's not an ally
in this particular fight for
accountability
that said if she really isn't an ally
are there any elected republicans you
think would be thanks for hearing me out
this is fine i mean listen quinn when i
say liz cheney isn't an ally i mean
she's not going to fight with us
for any policy issue
on our side it's not policy to say hey
the results of the election are what
they are
that's not policy so i understand you
know using this very specific
line she's an ally in this particular
fight for accountability
this isn't even really a fight it's just
we have an election and biden won
there was a riot incited and there
should be consequences
but the point i'm making is she's not a
political ally on issues of policy and
substance and i stand behind that while
acknowledging
she is on the side of reason when it
comes to just like the law is what it is
it should be enforced elections have
consequences and they're real i hope
that sort of clarifies quinn
ryan wrote in about debating quote gun
nuts
david sir was wondering what your
thoughts were on how to approach a
conversation with a gun nut
when they have the argument well if
someone had a gun they could have
stopped them for all of these mass
shootings we know that argument is
garbage but just wondering if you had
any tactics on how to handle that okay
so there's a couple different things
that are important to bring up in those
situations first of all
in many of these mass shooting scenarios
you only have to think it through to
realize additional guns would accomplish
nothing for example
the aurora movie theater shooting in
colorado years ago a shooting in a dark
movie theater it doesn't take much of an
imagination to understand
how
adding more guns in a dark room
so that there's more shooting maybe at
the real shooter or maybe not
and then potentially causing imagine
that you're the third guy with a gun and
you come in and you just see two people
shooting at each other
how do you know which is the bad guy
with the gun and which is a good guy
with it's absolute and total chaos
that's number one number two there are
numerous examples numerous examples of
mass shootings where we later found out
there were other people with firearms
there and they didn't act because of
exactly what i'm saying it was so
chaotic these things happened so quickly
that it didn't actually make a
difference now the counterpoint is
you occasionally hear about a gun
actually used defensively to stop a
situation and that's absolutely and
totally fine
but the bigger more common more
prevalent scenario is that more guns
actually add more chaos and overall
limiting the number of guns that are
floating around would have a much uh
stronger impact on reducing gun crime
and gun mortality
than simply adding more guns to
situation it's it's just the way history
bears it out
ramon wrote in about a famine and says
david in having conversations with my
family there seems to be a consensus
that an overall food shortage is coming
soon
i'm a new parent and as many others my
baby is affected by the formula shortage
already as it stands i know you've
spoken about this in the past can you
revisit
many thanks love what you do
the latest i've read is that over the
next four to six months
there may be a shortage of specific
products but there is not going to be a
shortage of any general food group
uh or nutritional source and so what i
mean by that is you know is it pos and
i've talked about this before is it
possible that
one
type of chicken
might not be available in your local
store yeah that's that's possible
but is there going to be no chicken or
no suitable alternative like turkey
or beef or whatever the case may be
there i've not read that that's really a
concern
uh recently
you all know i love my sumo oranges this
is arguably one of the top fruits in the
history of the world i would die on that
hill okay the sumo oranges
they're just guns they they come to me
they say sir we can't get them
and so i'm instead getting a super sweet
navel orange now it might just be
honestly it might just be seasonality
maybe this is not a time of year when
the sumos are available but the point is
citrus is available the exact type of
orange i want
is not currently available and it just
might be a seasonal thing so
my expectation ramon and i don't have
independent knowledge on this i'm going
from the reporting i've read
is there maybe a shortage of particular
products but that no food group
or a nutritional source like for example
dairy
meat vegetables fruits crackers etc uh
not expecting to see a shortage there if
the reality on the ground changes of
course we will tell you
evan wrote in about being tough on crime
david why don't democrats run on a tough
on crime platform by promising gun
control it's baffling that the party who
says they're tough on crime republicans
is also the one unwilling to do anything
to crack down on guns yeah i i
understand the logic of it right which
is hey
republicans say they're tough on crime
but they want more guns in more places
and absolutely no regulations
we are actually tough on crime we the
left because we will make it more
difficult to obtain guns and then commit
crimes with them it makes absolutely
perfect sense
the right will defuse those talking
points easily by saying actually guns
make us safer if we don't have guns to
defend ourselves with only the criminals
will have guns we
they have experience with these talking
points evan so what you're saying makes
sense but they will be ready for it
mason wrote in about the buffalo
shooting in my view on the death penalty
mason says hey david i saw a show not
too long ago where you said you don't
believe in the death penalty
i like to say i don't support it you
don't believe in the death penalty
because the justice system makes
mistakes and those mistakes cannot be
corrected once someone is put to death i
was wondering if your opinion would
change based on the facts of the current
shooting at the buffalo store we have
video evidence that this kid murdered
innocent people as well as a 100 plus
page manifesto with his motives do you
think it's still a better option to let
the kid live the last rest of his life
in prison i do first of all
if we are let's just start first first
with what's the worst punishment
based on my beliefs about what happens
when we die i believe if you put the kid
to death and we i shouldn't even be
saying the kid we're talking about an
adult here who did something absolutely
horrifying
when you put this 18 year old to death
lights go out and that's it doesn't have
to live for decades with what he did
sitting in a prison cell so if you ask
me
what's the harsher punishment it's oh
you're 18
the rest of your life whether it be 60
70 80 more years
you're going to do nothing
you're going to sit in a prison cell
and that's it it's it's over for you
that to me is the harsher penalty so
number one if we just start with what's
the harsher penalty i would go there
um
and then beyond that
all of my same opposition to the death
death penalty stands the government
shouldn't be in the business of putting
people to death yes he arguably has uh
um given out given up
his right to live freely in the world
okay well take it away by putting him in
a prison cell for life
don't take it away by saying well we'll
also do some killing and then there's
all the other arguments that are made so
no mazin even in this case i am not for
the death penalty couple bonus ones from
youtube droned on youtube said david
calls himself an independent reporter no
i don't i'm not a reporter i'm a
commentator
so funny he doesn't even know if he
identifies as a guy or a girl give me a
break no i identify as a guy
very confused viewer
also one other from droned who says this
pacman is a joke i cannot wait till this
economy is in world war three and see
what third gender he wants to talk about
i i don't talk about third we barely
talk about gender on the show
and i also while i don't make economic
predictions typically
my expectation is inflation has peaked
and will start to decline
and that we are
getting closer
to the stock market bottom now
obviously that's kind of meaningless
we're always one day closer to the
bottom even if we're not there yet
uh but i don't i don't even know what
this person's talking about and lastly
claude wrote in this pacman guy is just
a mouthpiece for the biden gang what a
joke imagine how much education was
wasted to create this propagandist
liar
um yeah i don't the one thing i don't
think you can say about this show is
that we're mouthpieces for the biden
gang in fact
i find biden pretty uninspiring and he's
done you know three or four good things
and
is otherwise exactly what i expected his
administration to be so maybe you're
thinking of another show claude with
respect send in your emails to info
davidpakman.com we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access
you